zu langsam zu wenig zu umständlich auf
einem impfgipfel suchen bund und länder
nach wegen wie es besser laufen könnte
griff nach der macht in myanmar putscht
das militär gegen die zivile regierung
und zu viel wasser
tauwetter und regen führen zu hochwasser
an rhein und mosel
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen schön dass sie dabei sind wie
auch norbert lehmann für den schönen
namen durch von mir seit fünf stunden
dauert er nun schon der impf gipfel aus
ärger dass sie nur so schleppend
impfstoff bekommen hatten die
bundesländer darauf gedrängt eine
video-konferenz mit der kanzlerin und
vertretern von eu und den pharmafirmen
fünf wochen nach dem start sind unmut
und die gegenseitigen schuldzuweisungen
groß hauptproblem ist und bleibt der
mangel an impfstoff und zwar noch
mindestens zehn wochen sagt
gesundheitsminister sparen bis märz
stünden etwa 18 millionen dosen
impfstoff zur verfügung im zweiten
quartal rund 77 millionen dosen
danach so die aktuelle schätzung für
deutschland würden verschiedene
hersteller voraussichtlich deutlich mehr
liefern
aus berlin patricia wiedemeier ärmel
hochkrempeln und sich impfen lassen
gesundheitsministerium und rk ii werben
für etwas was derzeit kaum machbar ist
endlich mehr planungssicherheit fordern
die bundesländer
wir hatten die aufforderung ja auch aus
dem gesundheitsministerium bereitet euch
auf mitte dezember vor wir sind
vorbereitet mit impfzentren und mobilen
teams wir kommen gut voran in den
ländern und nun fehlen uns die nächsten
lieferungen seit 14 uhr sitzen im
kanzleramt vertreter von bund ländern
und der pharmaindustrie zusammen beraten
wie wann von wem mehr impfstoff
geliefert werden kann
seit tagen erhöht die politik den druck
auf die pharmaindustrie ebenfalls in die
impfstoffproduktion einzusteigen auch
wenn es kompliziert sei es ist einfach
wichtig so viel wie möglich an
produktion zu haben denn es handelt sich
um eine echte notsituation wenn die
kooperation möglich ist aber nicht
eingegangen wird muss halt der staat
dafür sorgen dass sie eingegangen wird
dafür ist ja der gipfel da der druck
scheint zu wirken heute morgen gegen
bayer mit einer eigentlich nicht ganz
neuen meldung vor die presse konkret
bedeutet das dass wir für 2022
insgesamt planen 160 millionen dosen von
dem m rna aktien von kovac herzustellen
kurzfristig wird dass die probleme
jedoch nicht lösen noch ist der
impfstoff von chur weg gar nicht
zugelassen
dass aber auch langfristig große mengen
an impfstoff benötigt werden das
erklärte der gesundheitsminister heute
bei einer video-konferenz oben links im
bild wir wissen stand heute nicht noch
nicht ob es auffrischimpfung braucht und
zum zweiten kann es möglich wäre durch
mutationen die wir heute noch nicht
absehen weil das sind eben stoff auch
angepasst werden muss wie die
kurzfristigen wie vor probleme gelöst
werden sollen darüber wird derzeit wohl
immer noch diskutiert
grund haben wir in berlin dient dieses
treffen vor allem dazu die wogen zu
glätten
ja das dürfte wohl ein starkes motiv
gewesen sein denn alle die heute da am
tisch sitzen standen ja in den letzten
tagen doch stark in der kritik
das fängt an bei der eu bei der man den
eindruck hatte sie habe nicht richtig
bestellt die hersteller hätten nicht wie
vereinbart geliefert und bund und länder
hätten nicht ganz fehlerfrei verteilt
diesen eindruck will man hier
offensichtlich entgegen wirken und mit
diesem treffen ein starkes signal
aussenden nämlich das signal wir nehmen
die sache jetzt in die hand das ist
allerdings mit einem risiko verbunden
denn ein so starkes signal weckt
natürlich die erwartung dass es danach
auch besser wird und schneller und
einwandfrei läuft und genau darüber ob
über die frage ob das denn überhaupt
möglich ist auf die schnelle
da sind ja schon die geister in dieser
runde selbst geteilt ist die frage ob
man sich da einigen kann
einige bundesländer haben einen
nationalen impfplan gefordert also die
klaren zu sagen wann sie von wem wieviel
impfdosen bekommen
warum ist das so schwierig ja weil es
für einen verbindlichen impfplan
natürlich auch verbindliche
liefertermine braucht und die haben die
hersteller bisher zumindest
längerfristig nicht geben wollen
das bundesgesundheitsministerium hat in
einem vorbereitungs papier zum heutigen
treffen geschrieben es wäre schon sehr
zufrieden damit wenn bei diesem heutigen
treffen
eine planungssicherheit für die nächsten
zwei bis drei monate herauskommen
herauskommen würde mal sehen ob sich die
hersteller heute darauf einlassen und
ein weiteres problem nämlich die
nachschub frage wäre mit einem solchen
impfplan auch nicht gelöst und hätte
dann zwar termine
aber man wäre immer noch davon abhängig
wie schnell produziert werden kann und
da haben heute pharmaverbände und
industrieverbände noch einmal gesagt das
geht alles nicht so schnell von heute
auf morgen es lässt sich nicht endlos
beschleunigen
ein farmer verband hat es so ausgedrückt
eine impfstoff fabrik sei eben kein
fertig regal aus dem möbelhaus für diese
information live aus berlin chuck und
anna banerjee ein blick auf die
impfquoten zeigt wie unterschiedlich die
bundesländer vorankommen
die liste mit den meisten impfungen
führen inzwischen mecklenburg-vorpommern
und rheinland-pfalz an mit jeweils 3,5
prozent der bevölkerung deutlich
dahinter hessen und baden württemberg
beide mit 21 prozent schlusslicht mit
1,9 prozent niedersachsen dort starten
erst heute die ersten impfzentren
wilhelm tacke und fabian köhler
hannovers im zentrum am mord
die warteschlange ist überschaubar wenig
impfstoff bedeutet wenig termine
diejenigen die einen termin zur corona
impfung ergattert haben sind heilfroh
und kommen teilweise von weither sowie
hans und christa wischmeyer wir sind für
drei stunden unterwegs wir kommen nicht
von mir meine enkelkinder haben einfach
den termin geborgen hauptsache um einen
zu haben
gut 150 kilometer für die erste impfung
im flächenland niedersachsen öffnen
heute nur sieben der insgesamt 50
impfzentren für die gruppe der über 80
jährigen wegen den lieferengpässen lohnt
der start für die meisten zentren noch
nicht mehr impfdosen verabreichen das
würden sie auch in hannover gerne
[Musik]
in dieser größenordnung könnten aber da
sind wir weit von entfernt leider
niedersachsen ist schlusslicht im
vergleich mit den anderen bundesländern
doch die gesundheitsministerin
verteidigte ihren kurs wir legen eine
dosis zurück und verkaufen alles weitere
aber haben vor allen dingen die klare
konzentration auf die pflegeheime und
die werden zuerst geimpft deshalb jetzt
auch erst in einigen impfzentren angebot
für alle die zu hause leben rund 450
menschen wollen sie hier in hannover ab
heute täglich impfen
die kapazität würde für mehr als das
doppelte reichen wenn genügend impfstoff
da wäre
was also tun gegen den mangel an
impfstoff sie haben's gehört bayerns
ministerpräsident söder und auch
grünen-chef habeck schlagen vor
pharmaunternehmen zur not dazu zu
zwingen impfstoff zu produzieren
fragt sich nur ob das tatsächlich was
bringen würde und ob es durchsetzbar ist
jena niebergall hat antworten
wer den impfstoff entwickelt hat
produziert ihn auch so läuft das
meistens produktionslizenzen geben die
hersteller ungern aus der hand schon gar
nicht unter zwang möglich aber wäre es
das bundesgesundheitsministerium kann in
eine epidemie lage die
impfstoffproduktion auch gegen den
willen des patentinhabers anordnen
der staat müsste dann angemessen
bezahlen also ganz grob etwa 5 bis 15
prozent des umsatzes
manche tun es freiwillig das mainzer
unternehmen bei montech will sich vom
französischen pharmakonzern sanofi bei
der produktion unterstützen lassen
pure weg vom pharmariesen bayer sobald
der impfstoff zugelassen ist
verbunden immer mit der einschränkung es
wird dauern
geier spricht von einem produktionsstart
erst 2022 die impfstoffherstellung ist
ein sehr komplexer und aufwändiger
prozess sie brauchen speziell
ausgebildetes personal ganz spezifisch
auf die impfstoffherstellung abgestellte
herstellung straßen und herstellung
städten besonders komplex so die
pharma-branche die produktion der
impfstoffe von beyond moderner bald wohl
auch kilo weg dann geht es um diese so
genannten sogenannte boten-rna
technologie diese drei firmen beziehen
das sind im moment die einzigen
überhaupt weltweit diese die diese
technik beherrschen um impfstoffe
herzustellen die botschaft der
hersteller also eindeutig ob zwang oder
nicht schnell mehr produzieren das ist
komplizierter als es klingt gruner krise
was läuft schief beim impfen das ist der
titel das zdf spezial direkt nach uns
die korona zahlen gehen weiter zurück
allerdings sind die daten zu wochen
beginnen wie immer noch nicht
vollständig das robert koch institut
meldet 5608 neuinfizierte innerhalb von
24 stunden das sind 1121 weniger als
vergangenen montag 175 menschen sind in
verbindung mit dem virus gestorben
die bundeswehr wird morgen hilfe und
helfer nach
portugal schicken das land ist besonders
stark von der korona pandemie betroffen
geplant ist der einsatz von 26
sanitätskräfte für zunächst drei wochen
außerdem werden 150 feld krankenbetten
und 50 beatmungsgeräte bereitgestellt
portugal selbst hat sich zur eindämmung
der pandemie abgeriegelt angesichts der
korona zahlen seien nicht die zeit über
lockerungen zu reden sagen führende
politiker hierzulande südlich der alpen
in italien sind die infektionszahlen
durchaus vergleichbar oder sogar höher
und trotzdem wird über lockerungen nicht
nur geredet sie werden ab heute auch
umgesetzt
in den meisten regionen des landes
dürfen restaurants und auch manche
sehenswürdigkeiten wieder öffnen
annette hilsenbeck mittagszeit in rom
und die tische im restaurant il mattino
sind belegt seit heute haben lokale und
museen hier wieder geöffnet die meisten
regionen italiens sind zur gelben zone
erklärt worden in der das
ansteckungsrisiko als gering gilt und es
daher weniger einschränkungen gibt
immerhin bis 18 uhr kann man nun
bekannte und freunde zum essen treffen
wissen sofort hier her gerannt endlich
ein bisschen freiheit christina
colasante atmet auf wochen lang immer
wieder lockdown das hat ihren
familienbetrieb gebeutelt mittags
verdienen sie zwar nur ein viertel ihres
einkommens
trotzdem ist sie froh abgesehen davon
dass wir nicht arbeiten konnten also den
wirtschaftlichen verlust was einfach in
zwischenmenschlichen schmerzhaft so
viele haben angerufen und gefragt wann
wir wieder öffnen
21 kriterien hat das system nachdem die
ansteckungsgefahr in den regionen
bewertet wird die region um rom wurde
zum beispiel gelb weil nicht nur die
zahl der neuinfektionen sondern auch die
der hotspots deutlich sank zone orange
mit mittlerem infektionsrisiko sind nur
noch wenige regionen rote zonen gibt es
in italien derzeit gar nicht mehr dieses
systems ist dass wir woche für woche die
situation neu bewerten können region für
region zusammen mit den experten dort
und dann legen wir jeweils die maßnahmen
und ein
senkungen fest wie dort wirklich
notwendig das bringt akzeptanz und es
lässt sich schnell nach steuern falls
die zahlen steigen die meisten italiener
stimmen den maßnahmen zu und werden
zurzeit belohnt mit einem besuch im
kolosseum etwa mit ein bisschen mehr
freiheit und auch österreich will nach
sechs wochen lockdown lockern vom 8
februar an öffnen die geschäfte wieder
es gelte aber verschärfte
vorsichtsmaßnahmen auch die schulen
sollen wieder den präsenzunterricht
aufnehmen in einem schichtsystem und mit
corona tests ganz anderes thema ganz
woanders ein schwerer rückschlag ist es
für die bemühungen um demokratie in
myanmar
die armee hat die macht wieder an sich
gerissen schon seit sechs den 60er
jahren hatte das militär das land
regiert die symbolfigur des widerstands
aung san suu kyi saß lange im hausarrest
bekam den friedensnobelpreis
als sie vor zehn jahren frei kam endete
die übermacht der generäle
so dirigierte de facto kürzlich wurde
ihre partei wiedergewählt das sei betrug
witterte das militär und hat jetzt
wieder die kontrolle übernommen
über das land in südostasien normen
odenthal
das militär ist auf sendung mit glanz
und gloria was jetzt noch über das
staatsfernsehen flackert ist reine
propaganda die bilder passen zur
botschaft die kurz zuvor verlesen wurde
die hoheit über die gesetzgebung die
regierung und die rechtsprechung
gegenüber auf den oberkommandierenden so
wie es die verfassung in artikel 4 118
punkte vorsieht
eine nacht und nebel aktion geht dem
voraus parlamentarier werden
festgenommen internet und
telefonleitungen lahmgelegt soldaten
marschieren auf sperren straßen ab
setzten regierungsgebäude
der putsch löst unsicherheit aus und
ängste
die bevölkerung deckt sich ein mit
lebensmitteln nur wenige stimmen dringen
nach draußen die armee greift unser volk
an sie hat die zivile regierung
weggeputscht der wir unsere stimme
gegeben haben unsere demokratie ist wie
ein vogel der noch fliegen lernen muss
und jetzt bricht die armee unsere vögel
vor drei monaten wurde gewählt zum
zweiten mal erst freie wahlen in dem
land das jahrzehnte der militärdiktatur
hinter sich hat sanssouci de facto
regierungschef
er ringt erneut einen erdrutschsieg
betrug sagt die armee
doch beweise bleiben aus auch sotschi
wurde heute festgesetzt die
friedensnobelpreisträgerin hatte schon
einmal 15 jahre unter hausarrest
gestanden ihre freilassung der aufstieg
die wahlen ihren maschinen auf dem weg
der öffnung doch die demokratie blieb
immer angewiesen auf die gnade der
generäle und die wollen nicht von der
macht lassen
dramatisches spielt sich derzeit auch in
äthiopien ab die menschen in dem
afrikanischen land leiden ohnehin schon
unter naturkatastrophen
dazu kommen seit wochen heftige kämpfe
in der region tigray im norden des
landes etwa sieben millionen menschen
leben hier
die zentralregierung hat truppen dorthin
geschickt um die regionale
volksbefreiungsfront zu entmachten
die vereinten nationen sprechen von
einer katastrophe für die menschen
tim krüger berichtet noch immer gibt es
nur wenige bilder und kaum zugang zu
vielen teilen der konflikt provinz
tigray hilfsorganisationen schlagen
alarm vielen menschen fehle es am
nötigsten edward braun von world vision
war mitte januar integriert und konnte
mit inlands flüchtlingen sprechen
mein besitz wurde zerstört geplündert
auf einen truck geladen und von den
angreifern fortgebracht ich bin hierher
gekommen um mein leben zu retten
die situation ist sehr sehr
besorgniserregend es fehlt an
lebensmitteln wasser hygieneartikeln
anschutz es gibt psychosoziale probleme
die menschen sind traumatisiert
immerhin etwas hilfe kommt bereits an
hunderttausende in der region aber sind
laut den vereinten nationen auf der
flucht am wochenende besuchte der un
flüchtlingskommissar filippo grandi die
provinz tiger in einer virtuellen
pressekonferenz hat er heute nachmittag
die auswirkungen der kämpfe geschildert
das hat zu plünderungen gewalt sexueller
gewalt und vergewaltigungen geführt
leider haben auch sechs helfer ihr leben
in den vergangenen wochen verloren
vor drei monaten begann der militärische
konflikt über den es bis heute kaum
verlässliche informationen gibt reguläre
truppen milizen und soldaten des
nachbarlandes eritrea sollen an ihm
beteiligt seien unter den folgen werden
die menschen in der region noch lange
leiden zurück nach deutschland eilig und
bei kälte mussten gestern abend hunderte
menschen in berlin ihre wohnungen räumen
ein haus drohte einzustürzen weil eine
benachbarte baugrube voller wasser
gelaufen war
nicht nur dieses auch weitere 17 häuser
ließen die behörden aus
sicherheitsgründen räumen waren die
bewohner zurückkehren können ist unklar
das bezirksamt geht bei der
vollgelaufenen grube von baupfusch aus
der februar macht da weiter wo der
januar aufgehört hat deutschland geteilt
in zwei wetter zonen im norden schnee
und eisglätte im süden und westen sehr
nass auch hier gerät einiges ins
rutschen an seinem stern hat den
überblick
ein lkw und ein auto in die tiefe
gerissen ein erdrutsch nach den vielen
regen in rheinland pfalz in der gemeinde
kordel die landstraße wird zum krater
auto und lastwagenfahrer müssten ins
krankenhaus schwer verletzten das
aufräumen und reparieren hier wird lange
dauern
wir haben aufgrund der
wetterverhältnisse völlig durchnässten
böden und es kann niemand mit gewissheit
sagen
wie sich diese würden jetzt verhalten
werden völlig durchnässt das gilt für so
manchen ort im süden und westen des
landes wie hier das deutsche eck ganz
besonders viel wasser derzeit in rhein
und mosel und auch in vielen straßen und
kellern macht das hochwasser derzeit
probleme andernorts die beispielsweise
in traben trarbach sollen sandsäcke und
pumpen die überschwemmungen verhindern
klappt aber nur wenn das wasser nicht zu
schnell weiter steigt
die nächsten fünf sechs zentimeter
werden schon entscheidend sein und soll
das dann überschwappen dann kann es auch
ganz schnell gehen wenn die pumpen
ausgeschaltet werden müssen weil sie
leistungen über packen dann ist ja
innerhalb von 30 minuten ist der
stadtteil hier unten im uferbereich
zugelaufen
zugedeckt sind weiter große teile im
norden und osten schöneck in sachsen
beispielsweise hier gibt es derzeit
schnee eis und winterkälte sie sind
ziemlich groß die wetter unterschiede in
deutschland und das wird wohl vorerst
auch so bleiben
und da kann liverpool mit trainer jürgen
klopp nach zwischenzeitlichen
schwächephase den zweiten sieg in serie
feiern
3 zu 1 gegen west ham united die reds
auf tabellenplatz drei und wieder nah
dran am führungsduo manchester city und
united
liverpools stürmer mit salat zaubert
wieder vor allem in der zweiten halbzeit
jones --auf sala und dem gelingt es
gegen drei gegenspieler seinen schuss
feind zu platzieren 10 57 minute zehn
minuten später die sagt konter nach ecke
des teams trennt alexander arnold auch
shaqiri und der sieht moser der macht
was er am besten kann zaubern 2 zurück
es war ein wahnsinnsspiel von salewa
überall einfach weltklasse
und auch dieses zusammenspiel von
liverpool hatte viel schönes mein album
und das
13 01 10 gelang nur der ehrentreffer
dosen im 13 mit diesem sieg ist
liverpool wieder im rennen um die
meisterschaft
prominente verstärkung für die
abstiegsbedrohte härter sami khedira
wechselt ablösefrei von turin nach
berlin
der weltmeister von 2014 soll dort das
defensive mittelfeld verstärken
der 33-jährige hat mehr als zehn jahre
im ausland gespielt zuletzt bei juventus
war dort aber kaum noch zum einsatz
gekommen khedira erhält einen vertrag
bis saisonende
von morgen an die dfb pokal achtelfinals
ja unter trifft der letzte
regionalligist den wettbewerb auf den
großen erst liga nachbarn rot weiss
essen gegen bayer leverkusen nicht
gerade corona gerecht die euphorische
anteilnahme der anhänger am ku in der
letzten pokalrunde die essener fans ganz
im bann eines 3 2-sieges gegen
düsseldorf im dezember ihr torjäger
simon engelmann trug seinen teil dazu
bei essen in der regionalliga der
vierthöchsten spielklasse bisher
ungeschlagen krasser außenseiter zwar
aber durchaus mit selbstbewusstsein
ich glaube wir können ihm in der breiten
brust auftreten und das wollen wir auch
und wir versuchen natürlich auch hier in
der runde weiterzukommen gegen
leverkusen hier an der hafenstraße haben
sie schon einige triumph gefeiert vor
mehr als 75 jahren allerdings zu zeiten
von weltmeister helmut rahn in den 1950
er jahren waren essen pokal und deutsche
meisterschaft den 60er jahren natürlich
die unvergessenen auftritte von rwe
legende ente lippens kennen sie nicht
ich sag nur ich sagte die älteren unter
uns kennen das vielleicht mal ein
familienausflug rollen sich die kinder
im schnee und die erwachsenen schauen zu
ihr der umgekehrte fall während ihr baby
sich schon wieder verkrochen hat
genießen die riesenpandas menschen und
tieren im zoo von washington ihre schnee
rutschbahn
wer braucht da schon einen schlitten die
rodel technik natürlich selbst
ausgedacht zwei winter haben die beiden
kälte fans noch in den usa 2023 sollen
die leihgaben dann zurück nach china
gehen
das wetter bringt morgen neuen regen und
schnee die details hat gleich ist intern
viertel vor zehn freut sich christian
sie was auf sie im heute journal hier
folgt das zdf spezial corona krise was
läuft schief beim impfen
wir sagen tschüss und wünschen ihnen
noch einen friedlichen abend das machen
wir widmen
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter die grenze
wetterlage regeneriert sich wieder
einmal quer über deutschland weiterhin
im norden kalte luft und relativ milde
im süden und südwesten und es kommt
neuer regen auf im tagesverlauf morgen
vor allem von westen her und im
nordwesten geht das in schnee über hier
also glättegefahr
in der kommenden nacht gibt es ebenfalls
glättegefahr im osten hier mit
gefrierendem regen und überfrierende
nässe nach süden gibt es viele wolken
mit regen und einigen schneeflocken das
zieht allmählich ostwärts ab im westen
lockert es auf
die temperaturen gehen bis auf minus 7
grad im norden zurück über schnee kann
es auch etwas kälter sein
im südwesten sind es plus sieben grad am
vormittag kommt schnee im nordwesten auf
und es dehnt sich dann allmählich am
nachmittag nach norden und osten aus
ansonsten gibt es viel regen an der
ostsee scheint auch mal die sonne bei
höchsten temperaturen von ein bis 14
grad im südwesten
das geht noch etwas milder bis 15 grad
am mittwoch dazu zieht im süden vor
allem ein sturm durch im norden
glättegefahr
und die nächsten tage bleibt es bei
dieser grenzwert anlage ein schöner
abend